el camino continúa para esta caravana
migrante detenerse no es una opción
cerca de dos mil migrantes en su mayoría
provenientes de países centroamericanos
salieron de la ciudad mejicana tapachula
el sábado cinco días después el número
se ha duplicado en usted en el málaga
navarra porque me dieron papeles
negativos
a
muchos de los que lo perdieron todo con
el paso de los huracanes idiota y dieta
son niños y mujeres se calcula que más
de 1200 tienen menos de 7 años ese es el
caso de la familia de julio césar
gonzález que partió desde honduras con
sus dos hijos con el objetivo de
encontrar más oportunidades en el norte
de uno que no tienen nada en honduras el
trabajo a veces
toma la decisión y el valor de la riva
fue porque la cadena
emiratí que no tiene nadie deseas tener
algo intención de garra el valor para
que se pague arriba se estima que esta
es la caravana más grande que ha
transitado el sur de méxico desde que
comenzó la pandemia las autoridades
mexicanas no han intervenido desde que
intentaron mantener a los migrantes por
fuera de la ciudad de tapachula el
sábado el secretario de relaciones
exteriores afirmó que el gobierno
actuará con prudencia y respetar a los
derechos de los migrantes